ce jour là tous les yeux étaient tournés
vers le mastodonte venus d'ukraine et
l'aéroport de mirabel qui possède une
des pistes les plus longues du canada
assez longue pour accueillir le plus
gros avion du monde
l'antonov 225 à trois reprises et ses
petits frères néanmoins imposant des
antonov 124 pendant la coved mirabel est
devenu un centre important de trafic
cargo en particulier pour le matériel de
protection médicale mirabel est aussi un
espace de stationnement commode pour des
dizaines d'avions immobilisés par la
pandémie
pas mal pour un aéroport mal-aimé maudit
pour certains aient oublié pour beaucoup
depuis si longtemps dans sa première
phase l'aéroport de sainte scholastique
devait comprendre de piste de douze
mille pieds de longueur par 200 pieds de
largeur en l'an 2025
il devait y avoir six pistes semblables
ici ça aérogare six autoroutes devait le
relier à la métropole un train mule par
électricité devait par ailleurs
accomplir le trajet entre le centre
ville de montréal et le futur aéroport
international en 20 minutes seulement
c'était juste avant les jeux olympiques
de 1976
le projet routier débat soulevé une île
verte
son architecture si les epci purement
fonctionnel par les géniaux zitte et de
ses agencements par ces extrêmes
bâtiment technique tard c'est formidable
dimension mirabel en effet annoncé l'an
2000 francs l'an 2000 mirabel aurait dû
devenir six fois plus grand le plus
grand aéroport du monde
il est lentement devenu le plus grand
éléphant blanc du monde à la suite
d'erreurs et de mauvaises décisions du
gouvernement fédéral en faveur de
toronto et au détriment de montréal et
du québec
le scandale des expropriations a ruiné
la vie de
n 2 fermiers d'habitants pendant plus de
15 ans mirabel aéroports moody ou mal
aimé oublier est en train de reprendre
une place utile et enviable
même si on peut encore y voir des
fantômes de ce qui devait être le plus
moderne des grands aéroports du monde
les fameux transbordeur qui faisait la
navette entre l'aérogare et les avions
l'hôtel château de mirabel qui tombe
lentement en ruine et dont les
passerelles boucher ne vont plus nulle
part ni vers les stationnements de
chaque côté ni vers l'aérogare qui a
disparu le souvenir de cette aérogare
est resté pour ceux qui le savent
dans plusieurs films dont le plus
célèbre est justement le terminal avec
tom hanks devenu sans papiers pour cause
de guerre civile dans son pays
imaginaire d'europe centrale victor
n'avoir ce qui est condamné à vivre un
jour et nuit dans l'aérogare sans
pouvoir en sortir dans le film mirabel
devient l'aéroport kennedy de new york
en 2014 cette aérogare et démoli fini
les passagers mais place aux cargos de
plus en plus fin janvier 2020 mirabel a
retrouvé une vraie tour de contrôle avec
le trafic croissant d'une dizaine de
flotte cargo au fil des années les
chiffres augmentent énormément et l'an
passé donc on atteint les 90 milles
mouvement on avait besoin de passer un
service de contrôle d'aéronefs donc
services de contrôle c est quoi c'est
qu'on est plus directif sur ce qu'on
demande aux avions de faire la tour de
contrôle c'est l'original elle a très
bien vu quoi que c'est la deuxième plus
haute au pays
elle a de larges mais est encore très
très fonctionnel encore très au bout
deux jours on a une vue à 360 le con
quand même assez exceptionnel on est
très haut dit si on peut voir les avions
en finale à montréal trudeau également
oui on peut créer 5000 tonnes de cargo
la cuisson 26 transige à mirabel à
chaque année donc et on a une dizaine de
transporteurs tout cargo qui opèrent sur
les pistes de l'aérostier donc oui c'est
une activité et c'est une activité qui
va en grandissant que si on le voit avec
tous les achats qui sont maintenant en
ligne beaucoup de circulation de biens
qui doivent se faire greffer d'injuste
orale
s'il houle c'est d'envol y mx et le code
de mirabel rebaptisé aéro cité
internationale de mirabel par son
propriétaire
aéroports de montréal le grand virage a
été pris en 2013 avec l'arrivée des
cseries de bombardier
aujourd'hui airbus à 220 mais amélie
vraiment avec les amis de un des rares
si tout allait être aussi qu'ils sont
des sites aéroportuaires similaire mais
vraiment mirabel avec la diversité des
compagnies en aéronautique dont 92% des
activités amiral elles sont concentrées
sur l'aéronautique
il ya aussi une usine de moteurs de
pratt & whitney et des grandes
compagnies aéronautiques comme dolly
nord l3 comme astellia mecachrome avec
non loin bell helicopter et messier
dowty pour les trains d'atterrissage et
des recycleurs d'avion aéro cycle avec
l'aco vie de l'activité de mirabel est
en veilleuse mais prête à repartir
alors après le fiasco des années 70 80
peut-on parler de renaissance
renaissance
je pense que c'est ici on aurait
dynamisé l'est parce que les c'est
toujours existé a toujours lui de
l'activité mais je pense que ce qu'on a
réussi c'est vraiment le virage vers le
valais plus aérospatiaux peu plus
harkins prière en tout cas c'est l'heure
on est vraiment re dynamiser l'espace
disponible est immense et un dm croix à
de l'expansion